[Música]
dos millones de estadounidenses son
adictos a los opioides opioides como los
medicamentos que utilizamos para tratar
el dolor crónico ya sea a morfina y
fentanilo o el famoso oxycontin o
también a la heroína en españa 62 mil
personas están siendo tratadas por su
adicción a los opioides y como os
podréis imaginar esto tan solo es una
pequeña parte de aquellas personas que
sufren adicción api hoy des eaux
trastorno de consumo de otras drogas
como por ejemplo alcohol nicotina
cannabis cocaína marihuana
de hecho las adicciones y los trastornos
que se generan que se generan a su
alrededor son uno de los principales
problemas de salud en los países
desarrollados según la organización
mundial de la salud
yo personalmente pensé en estudiar las
adicciones porque me parecía increíble
porque había personas que consumiendo
drogas y aún sabiendo que es malo para
ellas para su salud pero también para su
familia continúan consumiendo estas
drogas o porque algunos de mis amigos
cambiaban su forma de ser
incluso mentían o se generaban excusas
en su cabeza para continuar bebiendo
hasta perder el conocimiento o hacerse
unas rayas es que estas personas son
débiles no tienen moral es que no les
importa nada no les importa ni su
familia ni les importa su propia salud o
su vida que les hace la droga en su
cerebro para poder ganar cualquier pulso
entre el pensamiento racional de dejar
tomarla y el la necesidad imperiosa de
tomarla
pues por el año 2005 cuando empecé a
trabajar en este tema ya sabíamos que
todas las drogas todas ya sean las
legales como el alcohol y el tabaco las
ilegales como la cocaína heroína lsd
todas las que conocemos o medicamentos
como os he dicho antes como los opioides
todas activan al sistema de refuerzo de
recompensa y aumentan la liberación de
dopamina en el núcleo accumbens
estupendo vale ahora qué significa esto
qué significa que aumentemos la dopamina
en el núcleo accumbens mirad toda
nuestra conducta diaria está regida por
las posibles consecuencias positivas o
negativas que tiene una acción sobre
nuestra supervivencia de manera que la
información de muchos núcleos del
cerebro se integran todos en este
pequeño núcleo accumbens y cuando
estamos delante de una situación o
sustancia que es buena para nuestra
supervivencia como podría ser la comida
el sexo estar con amigos hacer deporte
lo que sucede es que se activan las
neuronas de dopamina
y liberan dopamina en el núcleo
accumbens y esto actúa como un cartel
luminoso señala es una señalización y
nos dice nos dice a nuestro cerebro
esta sustancia situación es importante
para la supervivencia de manera que por
ejemplo al comer aumenta la liberación
de dopamina mi cerebro me dice esto es
importante para la supervivencia y a
partir de ahí se generan millones de
conexiones y de sinapsis de diferentes
núcleos cerebrales con dos objetivos el
primero de todos aprender cómo hemos
conseguido comer
y el segundo poder repetir comer todos
los días por eso los neurobiólogos a
estas sustancias y situaciones les
llamamos refuerzos porque refuerzan la
conducta que nos lleva a repetirlo
pues bien las drogas todas ellas legales
e ilegales por diferentes mecanismos lo
que hacen es imitar a estos refuerzos
naturales y aumentarán la dopamina como
por ejemplo en la diapositiva tenéis a
la cocaína que tapona los sistemas de
reciclaje de la cob de la dopamina y
entonces aumenta mucho la dopamina lo
hace de manera bestial evidentemente al
igual que un refuerzo natural en este
momento nuestro cerebro va a aprender
que la cocaína es importante para la
supervivencia todos sabemos que la poca
inah no es importante para nuestra
supervivencia pero a partir de ahí
repetiremos el consumo y lo volveremos a
repetir porque es un refuerzo y en
algunas personas este refuerzo se va a
convertir en el más importante de todos
más que comer más que estar con amigos o
que tener sexo
de hecho a día de hoy todos los
científicos sabemos que las drogas
actúan sobre diferentes áreas del
cerebro como por ejemplo la corteza
prefrontal o la amígdala que son áreas
del cerebro que nos ayudan a tomar
decisiones a balancear los beneficios y
los riesgos a gestionar el estrés la
ansiedad las emociones si la droga lo
que hace es modificar la función de
estos núcleos realmente lo que pasa es
que toda nuestra percepción nuestro
pensamiento y nuestra voluntad al final
está sometida a ella
vale y entonces todos cuando probamos
una droga todo el mundo ya nos vamos a
volver adictos no esto no es así porque
si no en españa el 85% de la población
sería adicta porque el 85 por ciento de
la población bebe alcohol
no es así el 20 de la población es
vulnerable a desarrollar una adicción
cuando consume drogas aquí somos unos
400 personas
esto significa que 80 de nosotros somos
vulnerables a desarrollar en una
adicción y en estas personas lo que pasa
es que existe una transición entre el
consumo esporádico social con amigos y
el consumo habitual es decir estas
personas van a modificar su
comportamiento y van a hacer que
consumir la droga sea un hábito y un
hábito es algo tan automático que no
necesitamos ni pensar es como cuando vas
conduciendo y de repente llega a sacarse
dices ostras como llegado aquí porque
tengo el hábito de conducir pues para
estas personas es tan automático que ni
tienen que pensar ni balancear
beneficios y riesgos y beben porque
salen fuman porque se han levantado osa
o acaban de comer o están con el café y
así etcétera etcétera
los investigadores a día de hoy todavía
no tenemos claro por qué hay personas
que tienen esta transición y otras no
que núcleos gobiernan esta transición
núcleos del cerebro a través de qué
mecanismos porque si no ya tendríamos un
tratamiento pero lo que sí que sabemos
es que la transición del consumo
esporádico al consumo habitual siempre
pasa por que se modifique la función
normal del cerebro por repetir el
consumo de la droga esto es así es
necesario
está esta afirmación nos ha costado
muchas décadas pero gracias al avance de
la tecnología ahora somos capaces
incluso de verlo en la imagen que tenéis
proyectada tenemos la comparación de la
función cerebral de un sujeto sano
arriba frente a una persona que es
adicta a las metanfetaminas abajo y como
podéis ver el cerebro de la persona de
abajo tienen menor tonalidad de rojo que
significa menos función precisamente en
una de las áreas donde se encuentra la
dopamina
y es muy muy curioso porque esta
comparativa es muy similar a esta otra
que os voy a enseñar estas son imágenes
también de escáneres del cerebro de un
paciente sano en el ã y una persona que
sufre enfermedad de parkinson y como
veis al igual que le pasaba al adicto a
la metanfetamina en la enfermedad de
parkinson también tenemos menos
tonalidad de rojo que indica menor
función en las neuronas dopaminérgicas
en esta relación en este momento aquí
reside el quid de la cuestión la clave
la clave que nos va a ayudar a avanzar
en el campo de las adicciones lo que
tantos años hemos necesitado de
investigación para llegar a esta
conclusión y es sencillamente que las
adicciones también son una enfermedad
mental
y como enfermedad mental merecen ser
estudiadas merecen ser comprendidas y
merece que diseñemos terapias para ellas
está esta afirmación tiene unas
implicaciones muy fuertes porque qué
pasaría si todos como sociedad
asumiéramos que las adicciones son una
enfermedad mental
bueno a nivel de políticas sanitarias
estamos empezando a asumirlo de hecho
increíblemente en eeuu han llevado al
congreso de los diputados la crisis de
opioides de adicción opioides que tienen
como una epidemia esto es algo
impensable hace unos años llevar como
una enfermedad como un problema social
una adicción
en nuestro país cierta vez que nuestro
sistema sanitario por lo general no hace
controles de rutina de consumo de drogas
de hecho
creo que jamás mi médico de cabecera me
ha preguntado si tomo alguna droga
tampoco ningún médico especialista me lo
ha hecho a mí personalmente
y además estoy bastante segura que si
nos lo preguntaran igual incluso
mentiríamos porque nos daría un poco de
vergüenza
lo que sí que es cierto es que nuestro
sistema sanitario existen unidades
específicas para el tratamiento de las
adicciones se llaman ucas son unidades
de conductas adictivas y en ellas se
trata adicción a cualquier tipo de droga
pero como también os podréis imaginar
hay una falta de recursos para estas
unidades y no se llega a atender a toda
la población que lo necesita
a nivel de investigación no no hace
falta ni que hable porque ya a nivel de
investigación en general andamos escasos
pero la investigación en materia de
drogas tiene muy pequeño presupuesto y
un modesto plan nacional sobre drogas
reparte un poquito de dinero para
investigar un problema sanitario que tan
solo en el caso del alcoholismo nos
cuesta anualmente en españa el 5 por
ciento del pib una cosita alrededor de
un millón y medio de euros anuales
pero desde luego no estamos preparados
todavía como sociedad ni como amigos
personas familiares a asumir que las
drogas que la adicción a las drogas son
una enfermedad porque os imaginais en
esta imagen que después al día siguiente
viniera a vuestro hijo y te dijera mira
mamá he estado tomando un poco de
alcohol y estado probando cocaína pero
creo que se me está yendo a las manos
esa conversación no la tenemos tampoco
la tienen entre ellos no se dicen entre
ellos
tienes un problema tío te estoy viendo
que se te está yendo de las manos qué
pasaría si en vez de tener este tabú
fuéramos más libres y fuéramos capaces
de hablarlo como cualquier otra
enfermedad probablemente seríamos
capaces de diagnosticarlo mucho antes de
tratarlo mucho antes y probablemente
también de prevenirlo
en definitiva normalmente pensamos que
las adicciones son una debilidad del
carácter o una falta de moralidad un
error que has cometido de hecho tener
una adicción es un estigma te señala te
aparta de la sociedad y es más si la
tienes la vas a ocultar no se vas a
intentar no decírselo a nadie estar
preparados a liberarnos de este estigma
a aceptar que las adicciones son una
enfermedad mental es un reto para
nuestra sociedad porque a partir de este
momento podremos diagnosticar podremos
prevenir y podremos desde luego
conocerlo tratarlo y probablemente
curarlo
y es por esto que hoy os propongo a
todos un cambio en vuestra perspectiva
que empecéis a pensar que las adicciones
son una enfermedad mental como personas
como amigos como familiares y como
sociedad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]